great thanks huh so so I'll be talking
about dense matrix multiply and using
strawsons algorithm particularly in
parallel and and this is work I did
while I was at UC Berkeley with Jim demo
who you'll hear from on Thursday and
also Ben Lipschitz and heard ed Schwartz
okay so so the the basic plan so I'll
show you new algorithm it's a parallel
algorithm for for strawsons matrix
multiplication so we call it
communication avoiding parallel Strawson
or caps and I'll tell you that the the
Cape's algorithm is is communication
optimal so it matches some lower bounds
that we know of first rawson also show
you that it's it's faster in theory and
in practice and to back that up I'll
give you some performance data and also
talk about some practical considerations
for using strossen and our parallel
version of it and so I hope by the end
I'll convince you that strawsons
argument it's not just a theoretical
idea something you learn in your first
duty class it's it's a practical idea
particularly in parallel ok and so so I
hope that this work will be a little bit
of a start to further exploration into
the tuning and the algorithm making it
robust eventually getting to a library
implementation all right so I want to
start with a little bit of motivation
the first bit of motivation is just this
great idea that that Strawson had so so
if you're not familiar with his
algorithm the basic idea is he shows
that if you want to do matrix
multiplication of two by two matrices so
so very small that you can do it with
seven scalar multiplies and a bunch of
additions so if you don't know it by
heart
I put the algorithm on on the left side
here and so we take entries of your
input matrix so say you're multiplying a
times B you take entries of the input
matrix a and and take seven linear
combinations of them so one is a 1 1
plus a 2 2 you take 7 different linear
combinations of elements of your B
matrix and if you if you do those 7
multiplies so this correspond to the red
cues and and combine them in another
special way you get out the output
matrix C and
so it's it's magic that all this algebra
works but but you get you get the right
answer and the difference is there's
there's seven multiplies instead of
eight okay so so that's great it tells
you how to multiply two by two matrices
the real beauty is that that we can
apply this recursively we can use divide
and conquer so you start with n by n
matrices and you divide them into
quadrants and now this a 1 1 is not a
scalar entry in a matrix it's now a
quadrant of a matrix and and these
additions and subtractions in the
algorithm they become matrix additions
and subtractions and the multipliers
become recursive calls ok so you write
down the recurrence there's seven
subproblems of half the size and when
you solve it you see that the total
flops the floating-point operations you
do for a major complication of size n by
n is in to the log base 2 of 7 and
that's a special number because it's
less than 3 so the classical algorithm
is cubic and and 2.8 is less than 3 okay
so so that's a cool idea so that that's
motivation number one so strossen says
we can multiply matrices with with fewer
arithmetic operations all right but but
something you've already heard and and
and we'll hear again this week flops
aren't everything right so if we want to
do things in parallel we need to think
about the communication and our
algorithms do so so the cost of
algorithms that computational cost is
important but we also need to think
about communication and this is this is
on sequential and and distributed memory
machines so I'll be talking about the
distributed memory case so we've got a
bunch of processors each has its own
local memory and communication happens
over a network but but the takeaway is
that as architecture trends continue
communication is only going to get more
expensive relative to computation ok so
the first ideas Strawson shows us how to
reduce arithmetic but if we want to
paralyze that we we can't we can't
forget about the communication and so
I'll be using this the simple model that
you've seen before
it's a well think about the running time
of the algorithm is a sum of three terms
one computational term depending on the
number of flops you do and then two
terms that correspond to communication
so we think about both bandwidth and
latency costs okay so with that simple
model we've got sort of two motivations
one is we know how to reduce arithmetic
two as we got to think about
communication
and when we first started thinking about
a parallel version of strawsons
algorithm we really came at it from from
the lower bound perspective so I want to
tell you a little bit about lower bounds
that we know now for for matrix multiply
okay so the story starts with the
classical algorithm folks have thought
about this for a long time so so the the
first result for lower bounds for
communication when you do classical
matrix multiply and go back to 1981 so
if you're running on a sequential
machine and you've got a limited cache
or fast memory size and call that size M
then this expression gives you a lower
bound on how many words you have to move
in that algorithm okay it looks like you
can simplify this expression and you can
but I've written a funny way for a
comparison later okay so a little bit
later the result was extended to the
parallel case so there's there's a
similar expression for a lower bound on
the number of words you have to move
it's basically the sequential bound
divided by the number of processors
you're using okay so that's great
those are lower bounds for the classical
algorithm so it turns out that that you
can write down similar expressions if
you want to run strawsons algorithm both
in the sequential and parallel cases so
so now this is why I've written it fine
so if you just change this three this
log base two of eight to a log base 2 of
7 that's the exponent in arithmetic for
strawsons algorithm you get the lower
bounds for for communication of strossen
okay so these expressions look very
similar the proofs of these lower bounds
are actually quite different but but the
first thing to notice is that this lower
bound on the left because seven is less
than 8 is less than the lower bound on
the right so so but this is important so
Strawson originally showed we can reduce
the rhythmic with with his idea but this
these lower bounds at least they suggest
you can also reduce communication ok so
that's what got us sort of excited and
and and we wanted to think about how to
take advantage of this opportunity so
let me just say there are other fast
algorithms out there for matrix multiply
if you're fast algorithm has an exponent
of Omega naught in the arithmetic that
Omega naught will probably show up in
the lower bound just just the same way
okay but I'm gonna stick to Strawson for
the rest of this talk so so
and let me point out there's there's one
other lower bound that that will become
important so in in the distributed
memory case there's the second lower
bound which is both of these lower
bounds are true and the tightest lower
bound is the max of both of them
sometimes this guy is bigger sometimes
that guy's bigger okay so so so that
will come up later and there's just
there's a similar story in the classical
case so the only difference is is the
red stuff okay so we've got these lower
bounds we see that that Strawson allows
you or at least allows the possibility
to communicate less than in the
classical algorithm so so are there
algorithms that attain these lower bound
that we have optimal algorithms in all
cases and and so the answer is in many
of these cases yes so these check marks
mean there exist optimal algorithms
algorithms whose communication costs
match the lower bounds and and the real
question that we had and in the
sequential case that sort of natural way
to write down the algorithm is is great
from a communication perspective it's
it's cache-oblivious everything works
really nicely and the parallel case it
seemed less less obvious to us and and
we started looking around in the
literature and actually didn't find an
optimal algorithm so what I'll tell you
about today is is the algorithm that we
came up with and and the communication
cost of this of this algorithm match
those the lower bounds that we found
first and of course after we came up
with the algorithm and we're very proud
of ourselves we found a paper in
literature later and had they had the
key ideas in it but there's some new
stuff in ours so I'll focus on our
algorithm and and and how it compares to
the alternatives okay before we get to
algorithms let me just say because we
were starting from these lower bounds
let me tell you some of the lessons that
we got because because we had two lower
bounds before we started looking for
algorithms
okay so the first one which I think I've
made the point already
the Strawson allows you to do less
communication in the classical algorithm
so if you design an algorithm for
Strawson whose communication patterns
based on the classical one there's no
way you're gonna get to the lower bound
so that's the first lesson don't use a
classical algorithm communication
pattern first rawson you need to use the
properties of strawsons algorithm for an
efficient parallelization okay so so
that's the first lesson the second
lesson
is that you want to try to use all all
the memory that is available so I've
written the the tightest lower bound
which was the max of the two expressions
I showed you before and if you look at
this first expression it's not
simplified but if you simplify it in
will show up in the denominator with a
positive exponent so that means if you
in in corresponds to the amount of local
memory each processor has or uses if you
increase that value M that means you
decrease the lower bound so if you use
more local memory there's at least the
possibility that you can decrease the
communication cost okay so and if you've
got the memory why not use it it's it's
not costing you anything else
so so that Nets that's the the second
lesson we learn from lower bounds try at
least to make use of the local memory
have try to use it in in some good way
to reduce communication so there's a
limit to how much you can do that
this second lower bound which is also
true it doesn't have in anywhere so if
you let in go to infinity and use it and
pretend your machine has infinite memory
there's a limit to how good that well
how much that will help you like this
this lower bound will start to kick in
okay so so using those two lessons we we
started looking for algorithms and and
so let me tell you a little bit about
what we came up with but also some of
the alternatives that will compare
against so I want to start with
classical matrix multiply and basically
a cartoon version of many good
algorithms so I'm going to refer to 2d
or two-dimensional algorithms for the
classical and and the name comes from
basically two DD distributions of the
matrices so you've got input matrices a
and B in your computing C you distribute
them across a two-dimensional processor
grid and basically algorithms 2d
algorithms work by somehow communicating
blocks of a across processor rows and
blocks of be across processor columns
okay it gets more complicated than that
but if you're familiar with with
parallel classical algorithms think
canon's algorithm think Sumer the more
practical version and and but but this
this cartoon will suffice for now
there's there's actually also an
improvement called call 2.5 D algorithms
Jim's going to talk a little bit about
that on Thursday so so for now all I'll
say is when I say 2.5
think somehow using the little bit of
extra memory to reduce communication so
2.5 is a little more efficient than than
2d if you're if you're able to make use
of extra local memory okay so if I say
2d or 2.5 V I mean a classical algorithm
nothing using strassman all right so
there's there's a cartoon of the of the
classical story now let me tell you
about a couple natural ideas for
parallelizing strawsons algorithm so so
the first is is what we call 2d strossen
it's sort of combining the 2d picture I
just showed you with Strawson so the
idea is you you run this classical
algorithm in parallel but every time you
have a local block multiplied to do
instead of calling classical code
locally
you just run strawsons algorithm okay so
a simple enough idea and as you can
guess the communication pattern is
exactly the same as the 2d classical
algorithm the only thing you're changing
is what's going on locally okay so so
one of the first lessons we learned from
lower bounds is you don't really want to
do this if you use the communication
pattern of classical you're not gonna
hit the lower bound okay you do reduce
computation now so locally when you do
the block multiply raphson does allow
you to reduce computation so you get
some win but you're not really reducing
communication okay so I'm calling this
2d Strawson sort of 2d at the high level
and then once you get to a smaller
problem then you switch to Strawson okay
so we can flip that idea and and do
strossen at a higher level and A to D
algorithm underneath so basically if you
look at the picture on the right so
these these trees are representing the
the recursion of Strawson so if you
count there's seven branches on each of
these trees so if we run one step of
Strawson will generate seven subproblems
of a smaller size and so it turns out
you can run a few steps of Strawson and
and generate all these all these
subproblems without any communication so
if you use the right data layout you can
generate a bunch of smaller subproblems
to run without communicating but then
they're all going to be distributed
across your entire set of processors so
as you go to compute each of these
subproblems you need to run a parallel
algorithm and you can you can run a 2d
classical algorithm there you have to
run it a bunch of times
but but the algorithm works fine so it
turns out again using Strawson here
you're reducing computation but this
this actually increases your
communication cost the basic idea is
you're running a classical algorithm
even more and more times so so the the
communication increase is actually
exponential in the number of strossen
steps you take okay so this is a
trade-off you're reducing computation
but you're paying for it with more
communication
we're often happy with the opposite
we're often happy to do a little bit
more computation if we can save
communication this is not what we want
to do
okay so neither of these approaches
these simple approaches get us to the
lower bound I mentioned that the 2.5 D
algorithm so you can you can combine the
the 2.5 the idea for the classical side
each of these cases it helps get you a
better algorithm but it still doesn't
get you all the way to the lower bound
ok so after we we looked at these and
decided that that we weren't all the way
there we thought ok we got to look at
Strawson think of a communication
pattern based on on the qualities of
strawsons algorithm - in order to reach
the lower bound so let me just give you
the main idea of our algorithm so again
we're calling caps and and the main idea
is to figure out how to traverse this
this recursion tree of Strawson in
parallel and and and really looking at
every level of the recursion tree we're
going to make an independent decision
we're going to choose either traverse it
and ret first or depth first order so
these these cartoons should show the two
choices so if we want to take a BFS step
at at a recursive level that means we're
starting with a multiply of a times B
Strawson generates seven sub problems
and BFS means we're gonna run all seven
sub problems at the same time on
disjoint sets of processors so we'll
have 1/7 of the processors work on this
guy 1/7 on that guy and so on ok so
we've got to do some reshuffling and to
get that right but it turns out this
this is very communication efficient in
the long run okay so BFS is is what we
want to do if we want to minimize
communication the alternative is a DFS
so that means we're gonna solve each
subproblem in sequence but for each
sub-problem we'll we'll use all the
processors so we use all the processors
duty
time's that's not and once that's done
we'll do all the processes 18 t1 to
invest 1 and so on
so so red here sort of means active at
one time okay so thinking about load
balancing the flops both of these are
fine both we have perfect parallelism
from a computational point of view but I
mention that in the long run the the BFS
step will minimize communication so so
why would we ever take a DFS step and
and the reason is that if we want to do
this BFS step and run all these problems
at the same time we need extra memory to
store them so each of these problems is
smaller but if you add up the the space
you need for all of them it's it's a
constant factor more so this guy reduces
communication but you're paying for it
with extra memory but that's it's kind
of a good thing that's what we saw the
lower bound suggested that you have this
trade-off if you can use more memory
than you can reduce communication so the
algorithm is basically take as many BFS
steps as you can as many as your memory
will allow and a DFS step because you're
working on each of these problems at one
time you're working on only one of these
problems that at any given time you
don't need much extra memory so if your
memory constrained you take a few DFS
steps to make the problem smaller and
then you take as many be a fast as you
can okay so that that's the basic idea
sort of in theory in practice there's
there's a lot of different choices you
can make so so this this plot is meant
to show a particular example so suppose
we're going to take ten recursive steps
of Strawson and we have seven to the
fifth processors so that means we're
going to need to take five DFS steps and
five DFS steps but when when do we take
them so so there's 10 choose five
different interleavings of BFS and DFS
and this plot shows the trade-off
between memory and communication so
along the y-axis is a metric of how much
communication our algorithm will do and
on the x-axis is how much memory how
much local memory we'll use and so you
can sort of ignore the green dots
because they're they're not paths
they're not interleavings we want but
the red and blue dots sort of navigate
this trade-off between memory and
communication so you know if you've got
this much local member to use and you
want to choose this blue dot and that
minimizes communication so this is this
is the right thing to do in theory and
if you want to our theoretical algorithm
sort of basically gives these red dots
but if you're a little more careful than
you can get these blue dots and navigate
this a little more continuously okay so
a bigger tuning space in practice but in
theory that the BFS and DFS idea it gets
you to the lower bound so let me just
summarize the the asymptotic cost and I
really want to summarize by color so so
blue is the lower bound that I told you
about red means we didn't get to the
lower bound and green means we did so so
this is just to convince you that at
least in theory
the Cape's algorithm is is optimal up to
constants and I should say there's a
similar story in the classical case so
there were these similar looking lower
bound expressions there's some
algorithms that don't attain there's
lower bounds but the 2.5 D algorithm
does so so again this lower bound is a
little bit higher than the case of
Strawson but we do have optimal
algorithms and for the classical for a
classical matrix-multiply okay so so
that's the theory part and and so now I
want to get to some performance data ok
so so we want to run these on on big
machines very very highly credible and
so we picked we ran a couple of
different supercomputers this this plot
is a a strong scaling plot on IBM BGP
and so let me try to help you digest it
a little bit so so this is strong
scaling so the problem size is fixed for
all points on this plot the the x axis
corresponds to number of course as we go
write more and more parallelism and and
the y axis is a measure of performance
so up is good so okay the first takeaway
is that well the red line is higher than
the other red lines are caps algorithm
so that's a good thing the second
takeaway is that we're comparing against
both classical algorithms and those that
use Strawson to reduce the computation
and Capps is outperforming them both and
and in particular this dotted line
corresponds to
the best any classic elegan could
possibly do on this architecture so the
dotted line is a theoretical peak
assuming you do the two in Q flops that
a classical algorithm has to do and caps
is exceeding that met peak so so it's
exceeding the peak the machine by
cheating right it's doing fewer flops
but no matter how well you tune the
classical algorithm on this machine and
you can't you can't cross this dotted
line okay and and the the next sort of
qualitative piece to pick out of this
plot is that that perfect strong scaling
which corresponds to if I double the
number of processors I'll cut my running
time in half it corresponds to a
horizontal line in this plot so so as we
move right so we're sort of mapping to a
horizontal line up to a point and then
we start to degrade and it turns out
that the theory tells us exactly why
this has to happen but but before I show
you how the theory compares I just want
to point out that that if if you care
about the the actual performance that
our code is getting we can draw another
dotted line which is the best
performance we could possibly hope to do
given the number of flops that we're
actually doing so we're above peak
mission we're above the theoretical peak
the machine relative to the classical
flops relative to the actual flops
there's actually a lot of performance
improvement left on the table okay so
and even though we're beating classical
organs that there there there's hope
that forward for further improvement
okay so so I just wanted to point that
out but now let's let's look at how the
theoretical model matches to our actual
performance so as I mentioned we can see
some amount of perfect strong scaling so
close to a horizontal line but after a
certain point because of the two lower
bounds that show up communication costs
cannot perfectly strong scale forever
and so because communication costs and
don't perfectly strong scale performance
has to degrade somewhat and so we're
pretty close on this end there's
actually a bit of a gap between theory
and practice on this end for high
processor counts and and this this is
due mostly to network contention which
our our algorithm doesn't really
optimize for and our theoretical model
doesn't account
four so there's there's room for
improvement especially at the right end
of the plot okay so so this is a it's
it's not a huge problem but it's a
problem that's big enough such that
almost all these points are still
compute balanced so so these algorithms
are still spending more time and
computation than in communication so the
real win in the Cape's algorithms is
coming from reduced computation so
because things are compute bound because
strossen reduces computation that's why
we see a win over over classical
algorithms but the problem is we're
we're also comparing against other ways
to parallelized rasam and so I told you
the the previous approaches for parallel
audience trois and they didn't minimize
communication and so it turned out that
even though they reduced computation
because they either didn't help or
increase the communication cost they
weren't able to beat the classical
algorithm so with the Cape's algorithm
if you are able to minimize
communication then you can hide it
behind the computation and do much much
better than in the classic algorithm ok
so this these are these are compute
bound problems we looked at so far and
and just to show you another plot so
this is on a Cray machine and
qualitatively the plot is pretty similar
caps the red line is doing better than
the alternatives strong skills for a bit
but then performance degrades this is
another another big problem this is
basically compute bound so the theory
said that that Strassen doesn't just
decrease computation it also decreases
communication so if we had a
communication bound problem we should
still see some kind of benefit so we we
ran some experiments with with much
smaller problems so these two plots are
our strong scaling and now the dimension
is fixed to be less than 5,000 by 5,000
and we're scaling up to to many many
processors and now the y axis
corresponds the time not performance now
down down as good and and so on the left
is an IBM machine and on the right is
the Cray machine and and so if if the
the plot goes down that means you're
getting some benefit for more processors
if you got perfect scaling that
corresponds to this dotted line and
that's pretty tough to do on such a
small problem ok so there's not that
much of a win on the intrepid machine
the classical algorithm this guy in blue
does does almost as well but we see on
hopper so this is
this is a log-log scale on the y-axis
that we see a benefit from the classical
algorithm and this turns into something
like a two or three X beat up and and
this is not from reducing computation so
so all the time and all the points on
here are going to communication and
basically latency cost and because the
strawsons algorithm reduced the latency
cost compared to the classical algorithm
that's why we get the win here okay so
the theory of strossen reducing
communication that translates to the to
the win in practice okay but but we see
it the benefit increases with these so
the best benefit is hi hi processor
counts okay so let me go on briefly to
practical considerations and an interest
of time I want to focus on this this
last bullet so a lot of people are
worried about strawsons algorithm they
feel like it's it's an unstable
algorithm and I can't run it because the
errors will be catastrophic so so I want
to try to convince you that that it's
it's it's a fair claim but but you
shouldn't worry so much okay so first of
all the the Cape's algorithm is a
parallel version Strawson it doesn't
change the numerix at all so we can
really go back to all the things that
people have studied for a long time
about Strawson stability and and so
there is a weaker stability guarantee
for Strawson than for the classical
algorithm if you do a fast algorithm you
can't guarantee as tight air bounds but
the the air bounds can be improved with
with various techniques things like
diagonal scaling so so there is hope
furthermore the bounds are better when
you take fewer Strawson steps and so
this plot shows both theoretical bound
and an actual bound and along the x-axis
I'm vary the number of Strawson steps we
take so if you don't take any strossen
steps at all then you're just doing the
classical algorithm and the far right
you're doing pure Strawson all the way
down to 2 by 2 matrices and the
theoretical bound in red it looks bad
especially at the right end and blue for
a reasonably reasonably condition matrix
it's
not bad at all at the far right end
you're going from something like double
precision a single but the good thing is
for performance reasons you you're never
going to run strossen all the way down
to two by two matrices so so really for
a matrix of this size you'll want to run
about four or five strossen steps and
the loss inaccuracy may be two digits
and the worst entry in your output
matrix so so it's not horribly unstable
there is a loss but it's not not as bad
as you think okay so so let me just wrap
up and summarize I told you about the
Cape's algorithm and that it's
communication optimal it matches these
lower bounds that we have up to constant
factors I show you that it was faster
both in theory and then and from the
performance results we see that it can
be it can be better in practice as well
and so I just want to argue that that
from at least these examples we see that
it that strawsons algorithm especially
when we go up to high processor counts
it can be practical and I think it
should be should be used more and
thought about more and there's lots of
room for improvement as well ok thank
you very much